hey i'm kevin hi i'm jess hi i'm tony
and today we're going to be drawing an
original character
based only on its voice this is my day
and i'm excited
it's going to be great if you call
almost thrown up in my mouth excited
yeah
i'm ready it's going to be it's going to
be fine trust me it's gonna be fun
i trust you kevin you're the way
all right so let's welcome today's
stranger
stranger can you introduce yourself yes
hello
my name is squirt and i
am here to play with you because it's
going to be fun
and i'm very excited
aren't you adorable oh my gosh
this is great this is great this is so
cute
okay so here's how it works squirt can't
see our screens we can't see each
other's screens
so the only way we know what to draw is
by what squirt tells us
and if you're playing along at home be
sure to post your drawing and tag us on
instagram and twitter
at drop show how young or how old
are you i i'm the same age as all my
brothers
and sisters we're all
um six years old six years old
okay are you are you an animal squirt
yes i am thank you for noticing
oh okay
we all have been like ah
oh you are a cute little adorable bunny
rabbit aren't you
no that's silly that's not funny
are you a land animal
or a sea animal or an air animal i like
to be in the ocean
okay oh squirt is an
aquatic thing do you have a shell on
your back maybe squirt
no i don't because it would get in the
way of squishing into
things okay oh
octopus that's right
[Music]
you can also my mom says you can also
say stuff with a cephalopod encephalopod
are you kind of a very kind of curious
kind of
kind of kind of curious about about
different things about the world
like learning about stuff i like to see
things that
are interesting and new there's this one
place
that um there is a big big big big big
big whale
and he's so big that um he doesn't even
see me because i'm so little
because he's so big he's so big he's so
big
is he big um uh he's very like by
himself a lot i think he's lonely
oh well squirt maybe you can be his
friend that's what i think too
but i have to get by his eyeball so he
sees me
how how are you how are you guys
approaching this
having having a little bit more of what
the character tends to
do uh helps to inform kind of
uh the the kind of the design of the
character really
that's something that i've loved ever
since i was a kid is watching
like animal uh uh or nature
documentaries
and there's so many different reasons
there's so many different ways for
animals to look
and it's all functional so knowing what
squirt does
helps a lot interesting you guys are
going functional
you know jess is right she's thinking
about from like a story standpoint too
what is squirt's character
what do they like to do to me i think
squirt
it sounds like is kind of a spunky
character that likes to explore her
environment
so i'm going to try and go in that
direction a little bit well i'm
literally just trying to draw a
cephalopod
do you happen to have like spots or
i have big spots on the top of my head
and in my body
and then some i have little baby ones on
my face
okay okay and uh sometimes
when i'm doing um some stuff where
we're playing the games where it's very
sandy and we kicking up the sand i have
to wear my goggles
goggles oh goggles huh oh boy
who had goggles on their bingo sheets
nobody's here i'm adding goggles
as we speak let's see we'll see ah
boy let's see i'll i'll add them at the
end what's your favorite color
i like the rainbow colors because they
have everything in it and nobody
is left out that is a lesson for us
all so squirt what do you want to be
when you grow up
i want to be one of the um octopuses
that can go on adventures with the mer
people
and then we could go to all the places
and then i could go to
um to the there's a place that i heard
it's okay you're hyperventilating it's
gonna be okay
i think the little story it's okay
it's okay it's okay to be exciting it's
okay i got excited
do you like to swim in an octopuses
garden my mom has a garden
all right that was a beatles reference
and nobody got it okay
come on i'm just showing my eggs
squirt have you ever met uh ursula no
i don't know that one okay i don't think
she lives in the same
part of the ocean that i do you stay
away from
this i live in a part of the oceans
where they sing that song in the humans
they sing that
oh canada song oh
you're a canadian cephalopod
are you kevin aren't you canadian no i'm
not
why did you think i'm canadian
is that bad no we love canada canadians
are great
absolutely especially their cephalopods
and you're so polite
yes you are very polite squirt did your
mother teach you
uh to be that polite or are you just
naturally polite
i don't know what is not cola why i
don't know what that means because i
didn't
you're right evan is not the opposite of
me
also tony likes to give me what's known
as the business
[Music]
so is that good for
paying your mortgage
no look at square notes about morgan
squirt i'm trying to refinance uh what's
a good rate
it's all kelp to me
okay i am moving on to color how are you
doing
a little bit last minute last minute
fine tuning
and then into some color tony don't let
uh jess snow you um
you know she's she's going to come at
the last minute with something
amazing so oh i respect it
i've actually seen jess i'm a follower
of jess so oh wow
okay i've seen her i've seen her work
i've seen her in action
can i ask you questions oh sure
yeah how did you know what you wanted to
be
when you growed up you know squirt i'm
still figuring it out
if you got any ideas you let me know
[Music]
i think you're a very good talking guy
okay i'll take that thank you
who is your favoritest artist when you
were littler
well mine is tony bancroft
i grew up with comic strips and comic
books so my influences are like
john byrne from marvel comics and calvin
and hobbes from
uh you know bill waterson um charles
schultz like i said
well it makes my heart feel good that
that us uh us comic artists were your
your first influences absolutely mostly
you kevin
stop it the big influence for me was
teenage mutant ninja turtles
like that was that was what got me to be
i like turtles they're very friendly so
did you ever
did you ever meet your your namesake
from teenage mutant ninja turtles
uh kevin eastman i did not he does live
in l.a though and
one of these days you know when
quarantine is over i want to
see if he'll come on the show so yes
yeah so we have a little extra time i am
going to get myself in trouble
and draw goggles
we're getting adventurous now this is my
downfall so here we go
if we were all going to go on an
adventure together what will we
do
exploring i would uh maybe exploring
in some like underwater caves i know
some caves
i know where there's some
[Music]
nothing but nice to squirt he's he's
kind of
he's a human and with a human shoulder
they're very broad true you know i
animated a character on in emperor's new
group called
cronk very strong
and athletic that's just like you tony
i did take off my own you know my own
yeah i looked in the mirror
quite a bit i couldn't see it i could
see try and get just the right look
there
the athleticism that is cronkite square
do you think you'd want to have your own
show someday maybe uh
um if if my friends could play with me i
would like that
oh you have friends yeah i'm like
unlike kevin okay you have friends
how do we think we did oh i think
everybody's wonderful
we gotta use our imagination i really
enjoyed that yeah that was really fun
ah i had a great time i am so excited to
see what you guys did oh me too
too all right well let's send them to
each other
oh they're so pretty oh my goodness
they're so cute oh my gosh
wow i love the colors in yours
jess i'm so jealous and you got some
environment there
i have to say it again damn it jess
kevin with these big goggles
kevin's goggles look more like like uh
yeah like the slow glasses
like my mom that's like my mom's glasses
tony's got a he got a telescope and it
looks so good
pony can't repeat the same color
it's like you guys color dropped from
the same square you're such a pink
you're a pink lady it feels like that i
don't know thank you guys for drawing me
i feel really realer now
oh you are real squirt you're real to us
squirt and now uh we're gonna do a
special reveal we're going to see the
person
behind the voice so squirt if you could
please
turn your camera on
[Applause]
everybody hi she's got the pink in her
hair
yeah i do i do i do uh hi my name is
erin fitzgerald
i'm a character actor for cartoons and
video games uh i guess
people know me more from like ed and
eddie monster high ever after high
ask the storybots world of warcraft
league of
legends persona 4.
that's a lot awesome one aaron you did
such you did such a great job of just
bringing
the character to life through the fun
facts and it wasn't just a funny voice
but you were acting the whole time
and you were in character the whole time
that's because she's real because squirt
is a real person
and a real octopus because that's how
score lives all the time
so weird seeing your face and then
hearing the voice
i know i think that nobody should see
the faces because that is more believing
and then you believe it i i think that's
absolutely true when it comes to kevin
if we could see a little less
hey for a better look at these drawings
your drawings and to find out how you
could possibly be our next stranger be
sure to join us on instagram and twitter
that
draw off show and we'll see you next
time bye everybody
[Music]
goodbye
i squirt